you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network my name Steve
Anthony in each week I read a story from
American history to my bro Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about or what the
endowment will be because recently you
accused me of being your nemesis for
most of the episodes you are and then
how am i a bro right now well I mean not
that I don't want that because that to
me is better to talk to me like that is
way better yeah but the nemesis is a
complicated relationship isn't it
especially when it all just lives in one
man's head well swims in a pond of
delusion we texted today right yeah what
was the last thing you text it to me
it's literally [ __ ] off okay so now
people understand what what's what I'm
going through now our relationship is
purely one person saying what did I send
the other one it's this thing to be left
alone what are they all right so we're
on the road and we want to get lunch
those the only times we that's only
frame and frames per hour we 10 what did
I say to you right before you said
literally [ __ ] off when I say to you it
said I love you okay it's pretty damning
his jam-packed okay this is not gonna
come
five part confession now hit him with
the puppy you both present sick
arguments
at some point I'll put the our latest or
latest theme song into the into my phone
right so this is this is not a creative
decision you've made no it's just a lazy
slogging predicament
it's a sloth predicament huh oh that I
by the way would i watch the hell out of
a show called where you just set up
something very simple for sloths to do
but it's just probably not gonna like
Kennedy to cracker in an hour
wait what say that again huh Kennedy to
cracker and vanity to crackers yeah I
thought you said Kennedy to cracker I
thought your time like JFK Kennedy it's
a Kennedy at cracker it's what you do is
each cracker comes with part of the head
bit no huh and that's all it is
uh-huh and there's gooey filling that'll
get all over your driveway
what it's not a cracker it makes sense
what you just said who cuz yeah when I
was coming out it did not feel right no
I didn't feel right for anybody I got to
be honest all right
Gareth yeah we are brought to you in
part by quip quip of course I don't let
your toothbrush situations both you and
I have my son have my wife has everybody
loves it my son I get enough yep your
boy Jimbo Jimbo has one I'm a huge fan
look the holiday shopping season is here
and this year your gift can start next
year's good habit with quit quit is
something that's sure to put a smile on
everyone's mouth because it's dental
care they'll actually want to use every
day mm-hmm that's why equip is perfect
thoughtful a practical gift with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
toothpaste all intentionally designed to
make good habits simple yep the quip
electric toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations and a timer with a 30-second
pulse to guide your routine and the quip
floss dispenser has premark strings so
you can always use the right amount
which I love you do like that I do like
that yeah
Plus quip delivers brush heads floss and
toothpaste refills every three months
like that that's a great feature yeah
joint over 3 million happy customers and
check every one off your gift list right
now with quip it's actually a good idea
yeah yeah yeah so uh just go to get quip
comm slash dollop to save on a gift sets
and to get your first refill free with a
refill plan and they have watermelon
toothpaste yeah slide that out
that's your first refill free at get qu
IP calm slash dollop get quip calm slash
dollop and they have watermelon
toothpaste that's good what are their
flavors uh well they have the standard I
don't know they have a bunch of weird
like good like weird flavors though
flavors really possible
they have sloths cracker flavored sloth
flavor yeah it's not sloth flavored
cracker yep two things they have a pate
of a slot that you can push out of a
tube that's right yep we're also brought
to you by Brooklyn look sheets are
important I use them I are using cheats
yet I don't for a long time you're just
on the mattress no no never been a thing
completely invented but those of us who
do yes I
you spend a third of your life in sheets
cuz that's how much you're sleeping or
you should be sleeping yeah so you
should treat yourself well during that
time sheesh I'm super comfortable yeah
and that's why we recommend Brooklyn and
the sheets this holiday season it's time
to gift the ones you love or yourself
with something a little cozier like
bedding loungewear towels and more and
lucky for you Brooklyn and is
celebrating their days of gifting with
daily promotions on different items home
of the Internet's favorite sheets
Brooklyn's got over fifty thousand five
star reviews and Counting yeah that's
right yeah anybody best sheets and
loungewear so Brooklyn was the first DTC
bedding company a meaning they work
directly with manufacturers and directly
with customers no middleman just a
product a great product and service
now I'm a big fan my wife loved Brooklyn
and she'd seen before we started using
them as a sponsor let's see then you did
then you pretend like you did it on
purpose that's right yeah wait yeah she
was like oh my god you're working with
Brooklyn she talks like that
yeah and so we love them we have some
nice white ones user charcoal black no
that's not I don't even and but why
would that even be a dig I don't even
understand how that like in your head
where you're like oh yeah I'm getting
him like this so this would be called
talking sheet and it's not going very
well
you like softness comfort essentialist
to help you relax Brooklyn has it all
right now Brooklyn and commas having
their days of gifting or each day they
have promotions on a different surprise
item Brooklyn is so confident in their
product that all the sheets comforters
and towels come with a lifetime warranty
the only way to get access to Brooklyn
ins days of gifting event and free
shipping is to go to Brooklyn and calm
that's B R oh okay l INE an calm and if
you're just hearing this and it's after
the holiday season you can still use the
promo code dollop the dollops re at
Brooklyn and calm for 10% off and free
shipping any time Brooklyn and
everything you need to live your most
comfortable life mm-hmm your hostel also
we are brought to you by ritual sort of
subliminal which of course is a vitamin
situation an obsessively researched
vitamin for women right rituals
essentials have the nutrients most of us
don't get enough of from food in all in
their clean absorbable forms no shady
additives or ingredients that can do
more harm to your body than good
turns out knowing what's in your vitamin
is valuable it is it yeah because most
most people have no idea yeah I would
say and I'm just I'm just guessing I
would say the 50% of vitamins that you
don't know what's in there 50% of those
probably wrapped parts yeah yeah yeah
big player
my vitamin C it's just a little rat hand
that's right yeah my wife takes ritual
and she likes it she had stopped taking
vitamins because they make her nauseous
but ritual does not right that's magical
yeah man no offend no fishy breath no
fishy breath right I like fishy breath
yeah but still I still can get that from
a spray she takes y'all still slip a
little piece of cod in her mouth before
we make out interesting okay ritual is
true traceable and transparent for
obsessive label readers all of rituals
vegan-friendly sugar-free non-gmo
gluten-free and allergen free
ingredients and their sources are out
there for the whole world to see you get
it delivered you start a subscription
you can cancel anytime you want easy to
snooze it you know I'm talking about
sure better health doesn't happen
overnight and right now ritual is
offering our listeners 10% off your
first three months filling the gaps in
your diet with essential for women a
small step that helps support a healthy
foundation for your body visit ritual
calm slash dollop to start your ritual
today that's 10% off during your first
three months at ritual calm slash dollop
mm-hmm and lastly we are brought to you
by a third love mmm which is a bra
brassieres yep mine fit great well look
their bras are designed to fit you not
the other way around design with
measurements from millions of women
their third loves bra styles are made to
fit your life they have over 80 bra
sizes but know that the only one that
matters is yours thank you you're
welcome
look it's a perfect they have a perfect
fit promise every customer has 60 days
to wear it wash it and put it to the
test and if you don't love it return it
and a third-level wash it and donate to
a woman in need third loves a team of
expert fit stylists are dedicated to
helping you find your perfect fit fit
stylists are available to help via chat
or email returns and exchanges are free
and easy my wife likes it she enjoys the
bra situation chair I like to look at
them sometimes I'll sneak off with a
the bra and you know this is being
recorded yep
and they also give back like we said
they will donate the returned bras to
women in need pretty great they support
charities in the Bay Area and across the
United States
if they'll donate over 50 million in
bronze it's amazing for third love knows
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they are offering our
listeners 15% off your first order go to
third love comm slash dollop now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get 15% off
your first purchase that's third love
comm / doll for 15% off - days like Lady
Gaga said bra bra bra bra bra yes
isolate that Erin that's a don't isolate
that Erin isolate that Erin do not
isolate that can I point out that I have
a stand-up album called riddled with
disease that is out right now you can
buy through my website Kara throat calm
those it it's some people are calling it
the greatest thing that's ever happened
the doll would be on tour are all our
tickets are on sale right now we're
going to be in San Jose San Francisco
Salt Lake City Denver Cincinnati
Pittsburgh Cleveland Seattle for two
shows both shows on sale now are now on
sale Portland also two shows both shows
are now on sale Houston Vancouver Austin
Dallas Oklahoma City Nashville st. Louis
Kansas City Des Moines West Palm Beach
tampa orlando louisville indianapolis
minneapolis and detroit or royal oh i
have been compared to Johnny Cash not
your attitude and sexuality oh my god
stop talking you can go to dial podcast
comm and find out where to get tickets
to any and all of those oh my god why is
this happening Dave's taking off one of
his shirts to reveal another shirt that
is a San Francisco 49ers shirt which
again a team that Dave is from the city
but again hated the NFL until this
season when they got good why for those
you keeping boys
I've always ever since I was a boy
watching Dwight Clark make the catch
I've always liked the 49ers it's just an
interesting turn I think if listeners
were to go back and listen to some that
we're on last season you were talking
you would never find me say anything bad
about
certainly not sir though we should also
mention the the show we're gonna be to
start doing here right what are we doing
we're gonna start doing a monthly show
in Los Angeles yeah yeah okay yeah so we
should mention that we're gonna start
doing we'll have more information out
about that this week but at the dynasty
typewriter Theatre in Los Angeles we're
gonna start doing shows once a month
they're for charity for charity I think
the second Tuesday of every month we're
gonna do a show there and give the money
to some good charities and get some good
guests so that'll be fun so that'll
start up in February in Los Angeles and
we'll talk more about that another time
yeah yeah I would the Niners game that
is a pretty good game yeah pretty good
game yeah good stuff January 24 1848
year of our Lord Jesus Christ it's nice
to be back into American history you
know the last time we did a dollop we
were in Europe I saw that stop was in
Denmark where we're the number one
podcast number anyway I guess let's not
let's not sell fellate let's get into
the story James Wilson Marshall found
gold flakes at Sutter's Mill on the
American River in Coloma California okay
my first reaction was these are
religious flakes yeah of course the
Lord's dandruff yeah yeah this quickly
led to one of the largest mass
migrations in American history in 1947
senators who had a thousand 1847 sorry
right
oh this is 19 yeah you're right in 1847
San Francisco had a thousand people
living there okay two years later there
were a hundred thousand okay so that's
[ __ ] but it's a big pick up sure it's
probably because the 49ers were so good
day that's right because people love to
come and hang out with the team and
watch the team now that didn't include
its surrounding areas so they're
probably you know 300,000 people came
west between 1848 and 1855 hoping that
you know find some gold find some gold
yeah
ships from all over the world headed for
San Francisco Bay most of the ships were
old and worn down and when the crew
arrived they all including the captain
just left it and headed for the
goldfields okay so people would just
abandon their but there's a it's
essentially like you're pulling the move
when you pull it to the airport and
you're like so I was like sure you can't
park here and you like keep it that's
the move but it's with boats
that's right that's exactly right yeah
thousands of ships were left to rot in
dock well I would imagine that somebody
would be like I'm going to take this at
this time and just be like I'm gonna go
somewhere I'd find something well most
of the ships were deliberately sunk in
the shallow Yerba Buena Cove or taken
apart piece by piece and used for other
reasons okay all right sure
so strip that [ __ ] yeah I like I like
sinking it in shallow water yeah it's
kind of fun to see it dad I should have
stuck it more you got real lazy didn't
you hey I just wanted to get off in a
shallow part it makes sense but again
total half of its visible anyway it's
down kind of but no it's a good sunk if
it's officially so it looks like it's
just not its side that's a sunk boat no
no it's supposed to be completely
submerged I have to go but I just feel I
mean okay it's fine I mean you're still
standing on it yeah but look movable
okay I'm floating away on my suitcase
now that's a really weird decision by
high you go the wrong way oh my god
so some were stripped of their brass
then burned to make way for new arriving
ships we've always been great other
ships were put to use like the an antic
which was run aground in what is now the
financial district okay and was used as
a hotel in a warehouse the boat was yes
so they just ran it aground and then on
the show
we sell suits you know there's a suit my
dad came to town one said he wanted me
and my brother my brother and I to go
meet with him at a sushi restaurant that
he'd found and it was a ship on land
yeah and we were like oh this is where
you go to get food poisoning that's
exact I've been coming here all week not
be coming here that's exactly what this
is
okay and they sell suits Suchi the
Arkansas was turned into a bar okay so
this interesting customers who walk up
the gangplank from the shore to get a
drink
Wow so you get the whole experience Yeah
right all right
the female was turned into a prison so
they're now and they are just putting
these ships on land and then opening
them up as yes yeah so this is sort of
like because remember there's a thousand
there were a thousand people now there's
a hundred thousand so you gotta you
services right okay another ship was
turned into an asylum and now this is
again jail and an asylum I feel like how
big are these ships
I mean third I'm some bird ecent sized
asylum sighs well no I mean that's
that's different right but you know you
can have a mini asylum situation right
sure sure and that's what they did so
you so you have some sort of mental
issue I think the official term back
then was you go bananas and then then
you're in a ship yeah and then yeah now
I'm getting the comfort I need and then
you're like well it's it's on land and
everything yeah not good right perfect
that doesn't help the mental situation I
don't think any of it is about simply
does not help depression no yeah
everything needed to be used to keep up
with the exploding population was used
besides the gold miners there were also
entrepreneurs and criminals all of these
people needed to be fed okay well it's
time to get a ship on there farmers
couldn't keep up and food prices
exploded okay author author eva
croissant
it was a protein hungry town but there
was nothing to eat they didn't have the
infrastructure to feed all the hungry
male workers okay and right and what
about the females who also were around I
guess they don't matter okay and there's
barely enough food for all the men
what about us we're sorry obviously you
are in a terrible spot oh we're trying
to figure out a way to feed your
husband's you know get them nice and
they vomit into your mouth yes if
they're if you're lucky
yes all right so that's a good plan
anywho all right this place has sushi
going here that's just a fella eat a raw
fish oh my gosh that's the asylum feel
sexual oh my god so it would be they
needed a lot of not just vegetables but
animals and they needed chickens really
sure eggs were imported to California
from all over the world including China
Chile Hawaii local farmers grew
vegetables they could they could not
make chicken farming work Wow
California's tried to set up chicken
farms but they failed time and time
again chickens would die from California
bird diseases that was one reason they
they didn't make it okay so just like a
there was just an epidemic at the time
well there you know there's just natural
bird diseases actually out there that
you know the bird flu and whatnot the we
all know about and so they would just
infect the birds and then yeah but then
there was there were other reasons no
the chickens didn't catch on okay
they all tried like immigrant Italian
immigrant Pierre a Giuseppe Bertelli
Pierre yeah I don't know my parents
crazy
I like a spicy meatball he'll bring up
here some spicy meatball ah hey I'm a
French Italian people thought our other
accents were bad
nothing beats our Italian well again I
don't know we don't we yeah it's the we
that I'm just there's a chasm between
what we're doing so so Pierre tried to
become a chicken farmer quote as again
Chrisann 32 after escaping yet another
fire he made an auspicious damn they
just keep coming at me I'm starting to
think you're lighting up no okay I just
it just always fires around me laughing
real hard yeah fire look Jesus after
skipping another fire he made an
auspicious start on a new scheme raising
and selling chickens at $3 a piece okay
it's a lot of money value of the value
of life is astonishing I think three
dollars if yeah it's around W around
sixty bucks okay though though admitting
in his correspondence that he was now
spending most of his time looking
through garbage dumps in search of feed
for his chickens so the the chicken man
is I'll call him yes it's spending most
of his time in dumpsters garbage dumps
looking for fees to feed his chicken
right okay they like a chicken they like
batteries they like pipes sure line
scraps like a the side of an RV that's
what it chicken elite right that's good
yeah I like to picture him going around
the dump looking for it much like a
chicken pecks food that's right
Pierre you know there's some good stuff
here now you're getting Pierre yeah I've
got finding some of good things as
mostly visual yes without a translate so
the chickens so basically his chickens
were hit by a disease and then wiped out
okay he's looking but there were two
reasons the chickens my kitchen I'm one
it was too expensive to feed the
chickens because vegetables are being
grown but those are all being eaten
vegetables corn people are eating all
right so they are in competition so
that's what all the miners are eating so
you have to go to a garbage dump track
find some food and then the chickens are
weak and then yeah I'm sure you're not
designing a great stuff if there's like
basic starvation going yeah it's not
great it's not great you don't usually
see fun wild of women are just like
sorry can we get that seems I could see
that between the men are the chickens
honey come on come on I tell you you're
a woman am i right with that come on
lady you can eat your fingernails or
something like that yeah I see you guys
doing that you guys do that a bunch of
crude tents popped up as restaurants
okay hundreds of hungry men would eat in
shifts in the tents chicken adds we're
chicken eggs were going for as much as a
dollar a dozen
which would be $33 today okay wow I have
a few chickens that had been an SF had
been eaten by the newly arriving miners
so when they first got there they just
ate all the chickens he's dead of
whatever few chickens were there right
but for the most part it was you know
they couldn't they just couldn't raise
him everyone wanted eggs grocery store
is put up egg wanted advertisements in
newspapers eggs wanted how is like the
layman gonna be like I've solved it what
do they even they're just complaining
it's not an actual want hello I saw your
sign I'm the egg man I've got all the
eggs
I didn't do sorry I'm sage doing
Dave you just had a foul mouth down do
you now rare that is sorry I'm still in
the head of the turkey Thanksgiving was
so recently I have a transition to check
out at all I'm planning on doing quail
around the holidays
his quail themed so an ad in the Sonoma
County Journal in 1857 read quote wanted
butter and eggs for which the highest
price will be paid at the store next
door is Reid and frittatas blacksmith
shop case you can't find it I mean what
an era we're right next door to the
blacksmith yeah they probably just
opened up and they're just expecting
some it's not a great person to show up
like a store the store shouldn't have a
sign up front like we'll buy yourself a
sign the people who want the store
should be wearing that's right not the
store I came in here for eggs job eggs
no we came here for eggs we work here
we're the store do you have any to sell
us no I'm here I'm I'm here in the store
to get up in this door too
you must have something to sell us no
it's your store right well we're an
upside down store mister I would like to
I just need eggs and butter now you work
here put the apron on what hey can I get
some eggs of butter that's an impression
you use out rock-a-doodle that's why I'm
in here to buy eggs and butter and bread
from you all right well since you work
at the store yeah what I'll tell you is
I don't work at the store well here
there was a long pause where you didn't
say anything which makes me feel like I
do I'm confused
because it's your store right look sir
all I'm looking for is some eggs and
butter if you don't have any please
leave I'm gonna leave no you can't just
shift started
manager what you got promoted look
you're in charge of the egg search and
it's a lofty position it doesn't pay a
lot but if you can find eggs and butter
well guess what you work at the store
hey boys I'm here for some eggs and
butter
you should run you should get the hell
out of here put this guy in back what
put him in back I'll show you what we're
gonna kill him we talking about shut up
we're gonna sell him his chicken what
this man's gotta exit in my case okay
got him got him like a piggy come on
no one ended weird eggs being big money
people began forging for them I think
you're saying forging for four these are
eggs forging eggs there's a piece of
paper you're in a kind of fortune yeah I
thought I was going with like forging
steel sure after all the bird nests on
shore have been plundered they started
to look awesome man when someone found a
bird they're like 28 miles west of San
Francisco in the Pacific Ocean are the
Farallon Islands sure the islands have
been called the devil's teeth islands by
Mariners because of the submerged ridges
around them okay they have been
described as looking like a piece of the
moon fell into the sea okay you down
with that sure I mean I don't hope for
it but oh you do hope for it or as a
picture oh here we go okay so you say
the coast Miwa tribe called them quote
the islands of the dead author Susan
Casey quote I can't overstate the
dangers of that place and how hostile it
is to human life it's a place where
every animal thrives because it's the
wildest of the wild but it's a tough
place for humans Oh God dramatic music
swell in 1850 there were a ton of birds
and therefore a ton of eggs on the 211
acres of the Farallon Islands gosh each
spring hundreds of thousands of birds
landed on the jagged cliffs and cranked
out eggs of all colors and sizes my god
Casey quote it is really a different
place during the egg season there's just
the egg season so we have the egg season
and then we have town ravenous for eggs
that's right do you see I see the math
equation
it's a beautiful minding there's just
this din of birds that goes on 24 hours
a day the whole island is filled with
birds it looks like it has been frosted
with white no boy
Aaron is now in the raking and in the
India yeah you everyone's like what is
now we can finally tell what Aaron is
yeah there's our boy human man human man
so in 18-49 City Councilman and actor
David Robinson decided to make some
money with his brother-in-law okay they
sailed to the farallon's and grabbed as
many eggs as possible from the nests
okay
the seas were so rough heading back they
lost half of the egg what
so nobody wins yeah I mean you can't how
do you package him back back you can't
hold them in your hands filling eggs
into the ocean just crack crack crack
but they still managed to save enough to
make $3,000 by taking and selling
something they had no right to take so
they mate and that's that's a killing
back then $3,000 oh I'm sure yeah but
the entire trip was such a nightmare
Robinson his brother-in-law said they
would never do it again
okay Robinson made enough money to open
a pharmacy and from then on was
nicknamed doc Robinson okay hey B me
yeah he made off like a man right and
I'm sure was a really great doctor for
the era well if you open a story and you
have medicine and people to start
calling you doctor if you have a boat
and like medicine that's right and I'm
air quoting your air quoting mm-hmm oh
okay it's a scary looking yeah you can
only see it that was when you that's
that was like the the way did in San
Francisco to know that it was a super
clear days if you could see the
farallon's from the goal game okay yeah
it looks very difficult to get on land
and get off land yeah it's it's like
everything is jagged right yeah
word was now out however about the eggs
well let the idiot boat parade start and
people immediately flocked to the fair
lawns huh huh the egg rush had begun oh
good and these birds yeah
these birds from decades hundreds of
years have been like just taking their
eggs yeah it's simple place that like
have have a baby chicks and yeah and
instead now he was like we made
something called the Egg McMuffin stupid
bird
yeah pretty give me your baby I'm gonna
eat it
it's good yeah sometimes I put you with
it in an omelet what yeah you're flesh
and then your baby mix together mama
baby
nom nom nom nom I'm just here trying to
have a baby with me I can't believe I'm
talking to a [ __ ] bird okay so I'm
gonna fly wait wait this is such a rare
opportunity I don't feel like it is
what's the meaning of life birds don't
eat eggs I'm gonna eat all your eggs no
that's not your a false messenger yeah
yes you are tell the truth I'm gonna
hard boil some what others I'm gonna
poach over medium a big omelet YUM the
[ __ ] I'm gonna eat him raw right now
like rocky back the men became known as
Eggers cool so it was a night where made
way to make money two kinds of birds
mirrors and goals the mere nests were
high up on the side of the ragged cliffs
so and the Eggers had to climb over bird
[ __ ] covered rocks go up the steep
cliffs while that so the the mirrors
would fly off but then the seagulls
would attack would attack the people so
they'd be fighting off the seagulls
while yeah there's only so much seagulls
can do to attack humans I mean have you
ever seen the movie the birds yeah but
that seems like explosions sure car
explosion fare okay the mirror are a
black and white sea bird the cow
like a penguin I got a little penguin oh
well the last time we talked about that
species things ended well the Penguins
yeah no they were fine yeah okay I don't
know how to do this they do that butter
to that arrow through the Arab yeah
there there there's the guy he's okay
yeah they look a little magpie
yeah cute little egg so they had the
eggs that were the most wanted so the
eggs had a thick and pear-shaped shell
and were gray or turquoise and speckled
and they were as edible as chicken eggs
but twice the size right okay so win-win
went fine huge Wainwright yeah I mean as
long as you only value the life of your
people huge win
here join the biggest drawback was how
the eggs looked well the vanity of these
starving [ __ ] I mean just a little
spotty isn't it isn't it a little just
body
oh no when they cracked it open oh the
white part is clear and gelatinous that
sounds like ace no you and the one
visitor to SF wrote quote I must confess
the site oh it's white the second you
crack and it's okay it's clear
oh it's clear you know eggs are white
these once you cook them clear yeah okay
but these stayed clear I guess oh okay
weird weird it can scarcely be called
appetizing the whites though thoroughly
fried still transparent and the yolks
ghost eggs of a fiery orange color
almost red whoo whoa it's kind of those
thanks yeah go stay yeah we called
Satan's eyes but no yeah I don't want
those hmm
also a stale me reg had a heavy fishy
aftertaste starting to become less and
less so it's the trip well okay so stay
like meaning an egg from the previous
season right okay with stale so another
eater quote an overripe mere egg is
something never to be forgotten it
requires about three months to get the
taste out of the mouth Wow
so when you eat one has been around for
a while
yeah it's oddly release
very fishy yeah it's weird that it's
fishy still met the eggs hadn't hatched
when they should have so the Eggers now
want to avoid collecting stale eggs
yeah of course so when they first
arrived in May they would go up with a
cliff and smash all the eggs that were
there the brave technique okay so they
would just go up there committed egg
aside yeah they would commit so they
would smash all the eggs so they
wouldn't get any stale ones oh by the
way that's just good relations with the
birds if they're around for them to be
like we can trust these things yeah they
are they're our friends this way the
next day when they climbed up they there
would only be freshly laid eggs oh wow
Wow pretty cool right really really cool
yeah go man the eggs became an important
source of protein for the gold miners
and therefore had a high price but a
buck a dozen okay that's pretty good
sometimes all the way up to a dollar for
an egg Wow the higher the price the more
people wanted to come to the fair lines
and the more do it themselves we remote
right of course quote they were sort of
the other gold in the gold rush lucky
[ __ ] birds Yeah right yeah because
there was so much money to be made in
the egg game people began fighting over
the eggs sure in 1851 so really we've
never while we're not sperm any longer
we're pretty much the same yeah nothing
just a bunch of dumb dudes like give me
the egg oh yeah pretty blonde in 1851
six men sailed to the farallon's and
declare themselves owners by right of
possession
hey it's ours cos we're here next who's
got a question next we're in charge just
people are the worst it's the power of
now well I'm here all right here's the
deal
we're a monarchy I'm the king okay I
mean it's just literally like how kids
pretend now it's [ __ ] each other back
I'm gonna charge you everything and
you're my number two yeah so they now
claim exclusive rights to the nesting
grounds and they had created a company
called the Pacific egg company perfect
perfect now they're or usually around 15
or 30 men that arrived when the birds
started laying the eggs from the Pacific
egg company mm-hmm they came in little
row boats which is borderline insane you
understand Barry yeah they took ship and
sold the eggs 600,000 eggs were now
being taken a year Wow good lord quite a
turnaround well for the birds there the
bird oh it's an apocalypse Oh for the
birds they're like oh you step baby
right now they just keep eating them
journalist Gary
Kamiya quote these were rough necked
guys waterfront types climbing up and
pushing eggs into their special egg
pockets in their egg shirts what's the
egg shirts oh my god the man looks like
a human potato so it's like he's got
it's like he's got a bjorn of eggs yeah
it's like a bjorn of eggs but he's also
got a basket on his shoulder but yeah in
his shirt his shirt just looks like he's
pretending to be a pregnant lady yeah
and that's all fillet Wow well he looks
happy he died oh my god how happy he's
happy at the same time ships were still
crashing on the Farallones sorry you
mean restaurants were open restaurants
and hospitals are crashing into them yes
thank you it's much better the US
government appropriated the islands to
build a lighthouse
okay construction supplies could not be
landed by boat so the stones for the
lighthouse were taken from the island
itself perfect workmen crawled up the
hill with the bricks on their backs okay
this went on for a few days until the
workers refused to continue okay and a
mule was brought out to the island ah
mules can't speak English but they love
it oh yeah mules love carrying stuff yes
there was immediate tension between the
lighthouse construction workers and the
egg company men okay yeah I mean
probably different goals the government
didn't recognize the egg companies claim
but still let them continue to take the
eggs okay so this is where right like
you can still pretend and call yourself
a company but we're in charge well that
means a lot
yeah that's right thank you so much as
long as things didn't get out of control
the government like all right just take
the eggs right
plus it's doing a service right yeah
major service yeah it's clean Ambala the
birds thank you
yeah at the same time the egg company
owners didn't think the government had a
claim to the island as far as they were
concerned it was their Island because
they were there cuz they said thank God
they said ours there's a dibs yeah they
said dibs
mine mine mine when the lighthouse was
finished they put the lens in which had
been made in Spain they got like they
got like the biggest brightest light
possible but it didn't fit perfect
that's well listen I mean that's one of
those things that if right now you buy
something that doesn't fit like this is
impossible we did do they were the
Hubble telescope that's true but even
then it wasn't like the level of this
level of work I'm sure it was like the
deflation you feel when you're like no
it doesn't mean it's not you're not
putting together an IKEA dresser now
many times they try to put it in Oh the
amount of times Jimmy let me have it let
me have a shot all right all right here
try but try don't don't flip it too hard
we can't crack it Tara
[ __ ] it's got to get it I want to try
accessing probably I have a new idea
what I'm gonna spit in it what I I just
want to try it okay I just want to spit
all over it and then push try to this
sounds like something else is going on
okay stop it hey man hey guys help Jimmy
what are you doing I think if we spit in
there not there's no way it doesn't fit
if we spread it out with you I'm uh spit
so they had to knock the lighthouse down
and rebuild it oh my god
how is that because because it didn't
fit they needed it to fit so you have to
every part has to go down if that one
component doesn't maybe they just took
off the top it's still when it was done
four men were stationed on the island as
lighthouse keepers okay and they had to
deal with aggressive Eggers Eggers were
now supposed to have a license but none
of them did sure
so there's tension between the Tigers
and the lighters the Lichtman right let
me see a picture I have oh yeah so I you
know the way I assumed up I assume they
just had to take off the top okay but
yeah or the or you know or them I think
the top would be the only part that you
from my brief expertise yeah and you're
an expert you know of course as far as
the Pacific egg company we're concerned
all the other Eggers obviously thought
it was [ __ ] that the company had
claimed the island as their own their
own so the other guys keep going out to
get eggs - sure
[ __ ] egging seasons who became full of
violence just the way that with how we
work constantly is we find we find a
natural resource we omit immediately get
greediest [ __ ] we try to just take all
of it someone tries to like impose some
sort of like legality to it yeah and
then there's just like generations of us
just killing each other over it yeah and
then the whole time you're like this is
such a dumb that's just not how nature
should work it's exactly how they make
sure you were know
so one local said May to July they got
their gold flakes let's all move here
and look for gold
what are they got over there eggs let's
all go over there grab eggs one local
said made it July became quote an annual
naval engagement known as the egg war
rival gangs are constantly getting into
fights on the island
Dave these ran from just threats and
throwing of seashells at each other two
stabbings and gun fights I mean Dave I
can't I just can't I can't I can't you
done I think I'm done I think I'm done
that's a big it's like and each year we
get worse the like yeah let me just
start with guns like it started with you
know like any other conflict it's like
it starts small that eventually
someone's like well you know what last
year we stabbed him I'm gonna start
shooting people at the egg parade
sometimes the gangs would battle for
weeks on the island whenever these
battles were going on Sam Cisco would
experience an egg drought really the
best thing for the birds is that all the
people are fighting each other yes but
still not good for the birds long term
but for the temp for the temporary time
sure mm-hmm
many times soldiers or police were sent
out to calm things down
hey we're PD we got a complaint of some
stabbings coming on over here and what's
going on we realize you guys are
obviously it's the shells versus the
yolks again but we wanted to talk to you
guys make sure there's no real violence
going on a lot of people seem like
they're dead up here yeah there's not a
lot of violence I stabbed that guy okay
for the last time but that's just like
for the last time you guys cannot be
stabbing each other okay so he opened a
police department here right okay so
that's so that guy took my eggs look I
understand I put a hole in them yeah I
understand right yeah it's like what you
do
hey do you know ila rules you guys these
are Island rules I'm the detective under
the tag okay what did you hear that yeah
I'm the detective yeah no I got it you
got to let me show you on the card I get
that you see that yep I can read yeah
that's the ete gg yeah no I see it div
all right so that's got the leg badge I
get that badge then our hats get little
leg things yeah so this flashlight when
I put that flashlight
there's my circle yeah like an egg yeah
it's an egg so so listen we don't give a
[ __ ] right
like we don't we'll respect your
authority we don't acknowledge your
authority see the thing about it
the thing about egg island is its its
egg rolls no no you're drunk you've
stabbed dresses where birds live all
right and I'm the chief okay now what I
don't know I work with the shells I
gotta tell you this is the worst cosplay
of everybody involved be good
so soldier sir please would go out to
calm things down and when they kicked
the Eggers off the island the gangs
would often go hide in sea caves instead
of going back to the city don't see in
all those jagged cliffs there's all
these caves right so they get kicked off
and then they just go this island that
one's just housed bird families is now
has cave egg lunatics that's right just
hiding in it and then when the cops
would leave and they like passed by they
would just go back to the island
sounds like the cops are really good to
quote one tenacious group steered their
boat inside great a muir cave and remain
there for two days during which they
were drizzled non-stop with guano so
they just somehow got their boat in a
cave and then waited two days I just got
[ __ ] on [ __ ] out the whole time yeah
it's worth it
it sounds worth it and it wasn't just
happening on the islands boats carrying
eggs were now being hijacked Wow
essentially egg pirates were looking
between the Islanders what that's right
I make beard they would wait for the
boats to come off the island and then
they that's the better play yeah that is
the better you guys have a good haul
yeah all right all right give us
everything well I didn't kill them no
their egg pirates there were according
to the San Francisco Examiner quote too
many a bitter and fatal encounter
between large parties of rival claimants
in boats mounting small cannons I just
love how throughout our entire history
no matter what is coveted we will just
kill each other over it endlessly and
then once it's done or normalized we'll
be like what's the next resource forever
forever the rivalries spilled into the
san francisco courts who now had to deal
with a bunch of egg related cases which
included charges of petty larceny
trespassing property damage resisting an
officer and manslaughter
I mean egg island is a crazy place on
top of all this it was a very dangerous
job the Eggers had homemade crampons on
their boots that were made of crampons
so isn't that what you take when you
have
menstrual pain no first of all you don't
take crampons oh you get crampons
but crampons are like you can dig them
into the rock all right like a shoe that
is like a you know extra key digger a
digger digger yeah but in this case they
were just using nails nails made out of
ropes and rusted nails yep so here's a
cliff accidents and injuries were common
I mean this is like like free solo won
the Oscar last year for basically like
you that's essentially they are just
free climbing for eggs yeah yeah no it's
crazy oh yeah I don't even think about
that thank you think kid I had ropes
like come well they certainly don't how
they don't at all no they're just like
all right well most likely we die for
breakfast again
so accidents are common in 1858 the
daily Alta California quote and Egger
missed his hold while robbing at goals
nest over the edge of a precipice and
falling was dashed to pieces on the
rocks below put that in a paper today
[Laughter]
- two pieces a horrible description a
death yeah you hear what happened yes
got - two pieces holy [ __ ] you gotta be
kidding me
yep who's the best Eggman I knew he
almost got an egg - oh damn the
lighthouse keepers were also not paid
well at all so at some point they
realized they should be running eggs to
San Francisco and making some money
good so finally it's it's spread
everywhere everybody wants a piece
an agent 58 a new head a lighthouse
keeper arrived
his name was Amos Clift he wasn't like
the other keepers all he cared about was
getting eggs alright he wrote letters to
his brother in which he said how
miserable he was on the fair loans and
how he wanted total egg domination Jesus
Christ quote before I came here this egg
company used to have things all their
own way but since I have been here
things have taken a turn and they have
ascertained that I am NOT as easily
bluffed I think it will now be settled
and the egg company driven off the
island so he's essentially a poacher
he's uh I mean I guess he's a poacher
you know what I mean as far as how he
wants to prepare his eggs
he's just like a dictator an egg
dictator sure Clift figured since it was
government land and he was a government
employee the eggs were his again I mean
what was laws deal back for a little
while you guys I'm gonna take 20 years
off from being a thing just do whatever
whoo okay while I'm gone
whoever stabs the other group the most
kind of wins all right fine laws gone
for a while he said after he'd made all
his money quote the government might
kiss my foot and so up along yeah it
kiss his foot and sew up a lawn up along
up along
Legg I think huh are you saying suck his
dick oh I think so kiss my foot and suck
my dick I think that's a way of saying
that's right I'm gonna start saying that
well why don't you kiss my foot and suck
my dick yeah salting but salted buy you
that same month the daily Alta
California reported the egg company was
quote breaking up of the government
roads and had drawn lines and pasted up
notices notices warning the lighthouse
keepers not to pass them on pain of
death okay hey so certainly so it's
getting reamed up a notch they are now
threatening the lighthouse guys are now
enemies the egg company is now
threatening the lighthouse guys with
death are those all eggs yeah that's a
pile oh my god the constant fighting
hurt lighthouse operations still the US
government did nothing to kick the
anchors off the island or stop the
violence that was happening
local authorities begged the feds to get
involved but the people in DC did not
understand how much of a problem the
situation was becoming so DC was just a
different place back then just full of
people who didn't understand the
problems with others yeah yeah I'm so
glad that we live in a different time
yeah it's nice to live in a democracy
yeah
lighthouse keepers found themselves
caught in a crossfire between rival
gangs in May 1868 Odin group took over
the islands and forced the keepers to
leave Clift wrote quote we are now in
the midst of egg season and the egg
company and light keepers are at war but
after being kicked off the island
Clifton never returned to his post he
was removed for quote the under
assumption to monopolize the valuable
privilege of collecting eggs so they
knew he was a found out right okay he
was probably talking a lot sure he
seemed to be kind of guy that talks a
lot about the egg king when you live in
a lighthouse and you get a minute to
talk to someone you let it rip hi call
me the egg cake
we have another the lighthouse all day
just wanna let you know I had Sam wedge
and that was a big guy let in the
morning yeah I gotta go okay bye bring
out my puppets nope the Pacifica company
was made up of Americans they were also
a group of Italian born fishermen who
are not happy about the egg company okay
two Italian immigrants right I'm not
happy about their company sure the times
have been given access to the islands by
the u.s. topographical engineers are
they allowed to give that guess so like
we're topographers can we maybe a go to
the Allen um yes it's yours yep yep so
because of this the Italians weren't
gonna cede control to the egg company
they also hated corporations and what
they and what corporations were allowed
to get away with so we're coming from
Italy they'd you know they've been a lot
of turmoil right right and so well
they're like well these [ __ ] guys
this is not good the towns were poor
immigrants and this was a way to survive
getting the eggs away to survive not
like the rich guys just making money by
sending out laborers and doing to do a
dangerous job yeah so also around this
time tons of Italians in California were
giving to fund to help Giuseppe
Garibaldi or Garibaldi Garibaldi
capability unite the areas that would
become Italy so Italy's right now a
bunch of different separate things and
this guy is going to go in so a lot of
Californians were tons of money was
coming from California for the cause
okay so the egg company then files a
suit in court against the Italian
fishermen okay and the judge ruled quote
against the Italians who being in part
possession refused to obey the summons
okay
so they're on part of the island but
they refused to leave it they refused to
obey
it's an Italian standoff that's I think
that's what it's called meatball sure a
big spicy meatball I think is what it's
called really good in June 1860 the
daily Altha reported to the Chief of
Police of San Francisco Burke
sent two officers to arrest the leaders
of the Italians who were on the island
okay
quote they found two parties armed to
the teeth in possession of two parts of
the island and breathing defiance
against each other okay so things have
evolved yeah
so they've each staked out their area
uh-huh and they're and they're holding
each other off and you know and again
this is over eggs this is a about a it's
really about a good breakfast that's
about a healthy nutritious perhaps huh
the officers tried to serve the writ but
the Italians weren't having it they
managed to arrest three of the Italians
quote the rest vowing that they were
ready for a fight and would rather be
shot down than be arrested
that's how you do it that's how you make
a stand on an island I believe from what
I read that those are the Italian guys
okay so they're ready to die for the egg
cause so in other words trying to end
this war it's it's not gonna go over
easy Yeah right they were not enough
cops to deal with the situation so the
two cops returned to San Cisco
with their the three men they'd captured
and explained to the chief what was
going on I'm sorry what the hell is
going on chief let just give us a second
so these three Italian gentlemen are now
the three largest suspects we have in
the egg case and again there is murder
going on on the island I'm sorry there's
a lot of murder going out at the island
over eggs people love I don't know if
you've tried all my have you tried
omelets yeah I've had it I've have you
adequate right once yeah I've done it's
like a thinner a quiche exactly yes
there's so no I don't know I mean exact
so [ __ ] good you know I wouldn't kill
anybody over here well then do not go to
this husband because they will literally
kill you I've seen a man just courted on
a log like his skull just completely
penetrated by wood because he was trying
to take some of these eggs and here's
the thing some of these eggs they stink
like fish so I don't even know what's
going on
anyway the body counts at about 800 800
dead it's not fine
so the three men were charged with egg
crimes petty larceny for stealing eggs
okay
the next day chief Burke and a posse
headed for the fair lawns with and the
arraigning the remaining 11 Italians
were arrested without violence they
became a chef they were like all right
we're gonna need you to die over eggs
right but this was just a civil case
which apparently the Italians didn't
understand they not fathom our Lots The
Daily out that quote the case is merely
a civil suit filed by mr. Felton and not
the district attorney being employed
against the Italians the same charge
could have been made by the other side
and the arrests made in the opposite
direction right the dodge gives the
enemy several days of harvesting which
they could not otherwise have enjoyed so
it's immigrants come to the country they
don't know they don't know the laws they
don't know the rules and then these rich
guys are like your immigrant yeah and so
the Italians don't know that they can go
to court right and have them all
arrested also right so the fighting in
tape-on yeah it's cool the fighting
intentions continued for the next three
years the Italian group led at one point
we're led by a man named David
Batchelder now so the Italians are still
going back well I'm wondering because
the guys name is batch elder so I'm
wondering if other people have not
joined up with the Italians it's not
really an attack right well it's also
like I don't know where like you're not
gonna be like send word back to Italy be
like come come it's a really good you
know you think no we're in jail well not
in jail but we're in try again yeah so
yeah so the times are still going on now
this guy this guy david batchelor keeps
leading what are essentially like rates
like he's trying to get back on the
island sure in the spring of 1863 an
army of Italian fishermen under a
Batchelder headed for the farallon's
which they intended to seize from the
egg company but every time they went out
they were stopped by the US Revenue
Cutter service Oh Cutter service we you
know about the Cutter service right
our armed customs enforcement service
that was run by the Treasury and
apparently had boats and it eventually
became the Coast Guard but but it sounds
like it took a minute to become the
Coast Guard yeah for a little while for
like maybe a hundred year a little while
they were just like with it aquatic
stabbing machine there they were they
were customs enforcement but you know
but they were like military we're really
enforced yeah we're not gonna yeah
they're like the ice of eggs that's
right right so anyway the Revenue Cutter
service arrested the Italians and took
their weapons but the times would keep
coming back Wow they well they're also
like their [ __ ] immigrants and they
know they can make money and there's
food out there but this is this is sort
of the same bunch of people uh yeah I
believe so yeah they want it to be able
to take from nesting grounds or like we
want to be able to sure we want to be
able we want to be able to disrespect
the land as much as you guys yeah I mean
essentially you're tonguing like why
would these guys be allowed to just have
nature and own it I think that's what
they're saying right that it seems to me
right I don't know what the government
situation is in Italy or what like is
public private ownership and all that
but right there's always been a weird
thing to me were like the first guy that
got to a lake gets to own it you're like
well how's that work yeah so the they go
out there on June 23rd 1863 and they eat
at night three boats full of 27 armed
fishermen Italian guys arrive at the
Farallones and drop anchor okay they
even have a cannon on one of the boats
oh my lord and the fishermen then just
started drinking as did the egg company
workers on the shore so I mean literally
you are in an era where you're like if
we do it at night
they won't have any idea what's going on
because people like no no you get
shit-faced you can't do it at night so
they get really drunk and they start
yelling at each other yelling threats
the Italians also get really drunk the
Italians are drunk on the boats the egg
company guys are drunk on the shore you
would think like from a tactical
standpoint we'd be like and tonight
let's not a drink what I'm a kid at one
point the a company Foreman yelled quote
land at your peril
okay and Batchelder yelled back quote
I'll land in spite of Hell Jesus Christ
that's a good that's a good one land a
[ __ ] fight now
What did he say back honestly his
response has me a little nervous um I
wasn't expecting him to back down but I
mean they totally seemed ready to die in
the morning the italians got into robots
and headed for the shore the egg company
men started shooting at them the
italians returned fire including with
their cannon on the boat what if the
birds are like we might move this is bad
I think there's another Island the
fighting went on for 20 minutes the
first person hit was edward perkins an
egg company man he was shot in the
stomach several several others were
wounded by musket balls at least five
Italians were shot before the fighting
ended and the Italians headed back to
their boats okay Edward Perkins died an
Italian had been shot through the throat
and he died a few days later arrests
were soon made for murder Batchelder
turned himself in while others were
arrested their bail was $5,000 each
which is pretty much you get back then I
mean five grand you're not gonna touch
but they just like in my eye still have
been trying to pin down exactly legally
what laws this island follows because
it's like it of course it's within the
zoning
America so it's like it's going to have
their laws but for some reason these
guys are like if you're on an island
it's Lord of the Flies we're so we
literally could just kill anyone we want
over eggs yeah I mean remember this also
time when you can stake a claim and like
you know what I mean yeah I mean like
there's no legal owners it's just it is
it's a bunch of children just being like
sorry I got here last I planted the flag
all fives yeah yeah bachelor would be
found guilty of murder but was then
released on a technicality right he did
it over eggs that's right so he can go
yeah there's actually there's actually a
glue people really wanted to a it's call
Hagel the government finally realized it
had an actual problem on its hands after
the murder yeah all right but with all
that egg money to be made and it being a
source of protein for the city instead
of just shutting down egging on the
farallon's the government came up with
another solution
well the daily author quote we learn
that the government to the annual egg
controversy has taken steps to lease out
the property to the highest bidder of
course that the Secretary of the
Interior having given instructions to
the collector of this port bids will be
opened at 3 o'clock today if this this
if correct will be apt to bring this
interminable war to a speedy conclusion
so it's literally two days after the
shooting and they're like we need cool
calm leadership to figure out what to do
next we will sell it to the richest
person that's right because capitalism
will solve everything will work yeah so
obviously the bidding war is something
the poor Italian immigrants cannot
afford but a company backed by fluffy
men can read me Pacific egg company won
the bid and now
a government back monopoly over the egg
trade on the Farallon Islands and so
finally the American Dream fully takes
for the breeding grounds of the seabirds
would continue to be plundered but the
once vigorous a mere colony had been
decimated that meant fewer eggs were
being harvested profits are going down
because for some reason I don't know
what like I don't know what happened but
yeah the profits are no let's just go
suck all the resources and when it's a
husk be like why what happened how do
you think well being a corporation the
Pacific egg company looked for other
ways to take care of that profit all
right start eating human babies and soon
it was turning seals and sea lions into
oil
oh no there's a bigger what the [ __ ]
dude let's can we just make a deal that
from now on I'll let this one slide but
from now on no more no more oil animal
stuff okay it like combines and
conflates all of my fears and my
anxieties into one enormous like well
you know we'll do for the climate to
take animals from earth and use them to
pollute oh you don't know why gas upset
you've never heard the penguin episode
of Macquarie Island we did in Australia
that's it's oily it's what I call
spoiling so now I'm The Fairly dr. su
Singh these sea lions into like some
weird can you know sort is contraption
that's just cubing them until now on the
fair lines there were vats of boiling
blubber and piles of seal and seal on
bodies covered by flies okay so
what that should be the flag that's what
our flag should be I mean that's what
our Flags yeah all right Jessica
Gingrich Smith of Smithsonian magazine
quote this unsanctioned action filled
the air with the stench of burning flesh
and a thick cloud of smog that obscured
the lighthouse signal see it was because
of eggs it all started because of eggs
but then eventually were like well it
sucks
yes well just juice these animals that's
right the lighthouse keepers were not
thrilled the egg company became more
combative they demanded the foghorn be
removed because it was scaring away the
birds mm-hmm so safety first but the
horn was pretty important when it came
to warning ships yep then the company
the egg company forbid lighthouse
keepers from taking eggs that they were
just eating themselves so the lighthouse
keepers are not getting paid a lot and
they're going out and taking an egg and
eating it which is really the only the
only time where you go okay yeah yeah
guy just trying to crack an egg and sure
yeah so they are forcing them to stop
that which had been going they've been
eating the eggs until that ass was built
and it was important for them because
they had low salaries an assistant a
lighthouse keeper was not having it and
he went down to collect eggs and he was
attacked by the egg company men and
pushed over an embankment there nobody
there's there's one like they are the
eggs of a bird those are my eggs yeah
got my eggs yeah yeah that's the egg
company set up finally the government
had had it with the egg company I know
right real bizarre so the government was
sick of the egg company they had killed
enough people on egg Island on May 23rd
1881 the US military forcibly evicted
the Pacific egg company from the
Farallon Islands so the military yep
okay
only one guy LS would seem to be upset
about it from the egg company he wrote
an affidavit for an inevitable court
case that everything was great on the
island and everyone was actually getting
along he said even the birds have become
accustomed to the foghorn all was well
uh-huh but this was just because he had
been living on the island for 14 years
and wanted to stay so he was the
caretaker of that little set up place if
they had okay right the other egg
company men were thrilled to leave one
because the other guys were like
probably one time workers that would go
out for you know two months and just
make their egg money and then never go
back right that's a [ __ ] job right now
one wrote quote we steamed away from the
windy rocks to Howland caverns and the
sealing waves the frightful chasms
joyfully we bounded over the glassy
waves that grew beautiful as the fair
logs faded in the misty distance and
having been stood this to just find out
about the word misty misty and haven't
been courteously escorted to the city
dock were bidden farewell and left to
the diversions of the hour thus ended
the last siege of the egg Pickers of
Frisco the company men were left with
all their possessions at the end of
Broadway Street after 30 years of
fighting this was the official end to
the egg war but the lighthouse keepers
an independent fisherman kept taking the
eggs in the summer the government
allowed the lighthouse keepers to bring
their wives and kids to live on the
island okay one guy had a couple of
girls under 7 which must have been
really great for the girls yeah I'm sure
that's great
like hey and we'll just eventually make
up our own language and go crazy
together I mean it's it's a [ __ ]
terrifying place so this is how they got
between islands Oh
so it's pretty simple rope yeah no it's
just a pulley where yeah that seam is
called a bridge yeah that's he was
pretty straightforward and fun
and then after all this chickens became
farmable in California a successful
poultry industry kicked off in Petaluma
38 miles north of San Francisco someone
had figured out a wig iord out a way
to keep them alive and that was to let
them free-range and keep moving them
from place to place so they could eat
and keep like chicken would do in its
natural if the chicken could actually be
in nature I would act right yes so then
okay I'll get on my soapbox in a minute
so they they did that and so it turns
out the reasons that the chickens were
dying is they were keeping them in
paradise and then they had to feed them
right and then they would get sick he's
giving them a quality of life not a
quality life so a peddle Emma becomes a
huge chicken farming area so this stops
diseases from killing them the these the
environment for food chicken eggs become
plentiful and the demand for your eggs
drops as does the price soon the muir
eggs were selling for five cents a dozen
well how but the mirror on the fair
lines fair lawns were not devastated
over ten million eggs have been taken
over the years mirrors only lay one or
two eggs a year the egg collection was
now down to sixty thousand a year when
it had started at six hundred thousand a
year in 1854 the birds were making over
five hundred thousand eggs a year in
1896 it was down to ninety one thousand
it became less and less profitable to
steal the venire eggs but still some
Eggers kept at it the mirror situation
came to the attention of a scientist
with the Academy Academy of Sciences
named Leverett M Lewis and he started a
campaign to stop the egging and got the
Lighthouse Board to ban it the
farallon's are now used by scientists to
observe bird and animal life and to
track the recovery of species on the
island today the Farallon Islands are
home to a sea bird sanctuary with a
thriving but still recovering still
recovering it's still way not even close
to what it was that's just crazy your
population trying to recover species is
a huge and sometimes daunting task we
are still only at a quarter of the pre
Gold Rush common your numbers but I mean
like this did take them to the brink of
extinction
were you waiting alone No
[Laughter]
so sources for this when California main
sources were when Calvin went to war
over eggs by Jessica Gingrich on
Smithsonian magazine a website Susan
Casey wrote the devil's teeth the true
story of obsession and survival among
America's great white chicks and then
Eva croissant has a blog called
Garibaldi in the Farallon egg war so the
the reason I wanted RepA sewed is
because people don't really understand
what is meant by a green new deal and
what people are talking about when they
say we have to change everything yeah so
if the Italian immigrants had a social
social safety net and if the
corporation's didn't exist to plunder
then this wouldn't be an issue
yeah so when you talk about saving the
environment but you just think about
well you save the island but that's not
it like you have to take care of people
to stop the plunder and the destruction
and and one of the main most destructive
things is capitalism it's guys going out
there taking the eggs to make money as
opposed to people going out there and
getting a right amount of eggs to let
the population survive but also feed
people it's working with imbalance well
the truth is that when you when you look
at the way we harvest animals oh yeah
like it's like the fed the way I just
always think of like the way that people
fight like when they're like they're
trying to take your burgers it's like
well guess what
in this scenario of yours you lose your
burgers either way either
you create the boogeyman who's taking
all your burgers right now which is
really someone saying like hey you don't
get to have burgers all the time or you
know we need to figure out a new way to
farm or you will have no bird
yeah that will come true because
eventually it will be so unsustainable
yeah and when you're talking about
free-range truly this simplicity with
like if if you were to be a little more
be a little less I guess penny wise
dollar foolish what you would do what
most farmers want to do and what what
like actual farmers do who don't
practice factory farming is they have
the animals and they move the animals
they let the animals graze and like you
know take over a patch of land and once
that land is done they have a new patch
of land and they go move them and then
another land where they used to be that
they ruined regrows and stabilizes and
then you keep doing that so you
basically have like three sections or
you just keep moving these animals well
if you don't do that it sure it's
cheaper it's cheaper for your business
because you keep them in pens or you
don't really do much with them but at
the end of the day it again we are
talking about a time like you're saying
where none of it can happen right yeah
and yeah and our relationship with the
environment in our relationship the way
the capitalism like just you know takes
it over is just going to be what they're
going to be the term late on our
tombstone when it's all said and done
and and you think about this exact
circumstance well the reason that they
had to go out to the island to kill the
to take all the eggs and and decimate
the population was because they didn't
realize they just they just let chickens
free-range they would be fine like they
could have done that 50 years before
yeah and then would have been fine well
the answer is that nature knows better
yeah
major things better yeah and they were
trying to do like put chickens and pens
and have them in a city and what and it
yeah guess what it doesn't work but it's
also very similar to how we over harvest
oceans yeah like the way that like there
are sustainable ways there are like
places in the ocean where they've been
able to you know like they've decimated
the population of a fish and then they
go well here's what we do we now
actually you you do not you're unable to
catch tuna of this size so if you catch
a tuna of this size that tuna goes back
and you wait and then but because it's
like no demand demand demand you know
people will take out the smaller tuna
and the smaller fish and then
and then there's no younger generation
and then again you are like actually
there's less fish that you're actually
getting because of yeah and then also
dragging the seafloor yeah I mean it's
all we're basically what we're doing to
the earth is exactly what we did the
Farallones yeah basically we're doing to
earth it's like if you walked in
hammered to a New Year's party at 11:30
and just like went to town on the buffet
spilled the booze everywhere like
punched a couple people you're just
there for like no time and the party was
fine before you showed up but we're just
like and I pissed on the punch it's like
well now there's no we can't pile the
[ __ ] hey like on the calendar of
existence man has been here for like
half a day of beer yeah still showed up
at the end like I think we can get the
cops here in 30 minutes yeah anyway good
times yeah no obviously this is the
energy you want to leave stuff with if
you haven't seen oak jaw that's a good
movie too ah the tears that ran down my
face for hope Jeff and then close and
then go watch Paris is the same guy same
guy it's [ __ ] genius parasite is
genius
parasites genius yeah alright alright
hope everybody enjoyed themselves
please sign eggs we sign eggs oh by the
way I don't need those anymore
the vegan all right we're saying
gobble-gobble everybody Happy
Thanksgiving
we need to record a quick thing too